[ Cheers and applause ]
-I've been trying to keep up
with everybody
during the pandemic. Like,
I've been trying to keep up
with my granddad, 'cause he's,
you know,
one of my favorite people.
And he helped raise me
and everything.
So sometimes I'll call. He lives
in an assisted living facility.
And so I'll call him, and one
of the things that happens --
These people are doing
an incredible job.
But one of the things
that inevitably happens
is every time I call, they hand
the phone to the wrong old man.
[ Laughter ]
Every single time.
So then, through the phone,
I have to guide an old man
to my granddad, right?
And the last few times,
they kept handing the phone
to the same wrong old man
named JB.
He's a lovely man,
but he's not my granddad.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
And so they hand
the phone to JB.
And I'm pretty sure
his name is JB
because he was born before
full names came out, alright?
This dude was born when there
were J's and there were B's,
and then he put them together,
you know?
He is the most 98-year-old man
I have ever come in contact with
in my life.
So then they hand the phone
to JB, and I say, "Hello, JB,"
and then he says,
"How do you know who I am?"
[ Laughter ]
And then I have to
explain to him,
"Sir, I'm actually
your roommate's grandson, okay?
So we've actually had
lots of conversations.
I was just wondering
if you could hand the phone
to my granddad."
And then he's like, "I don't
think I know who that is."
And I'm like,
"Yes, sir, you do.
He's your roommate.
He should be right there."
And he's like,
"I'm not sure about that."
And so then finally,
I have to ask him,
"Sir, is there an old Black man
wearing a conductor's hat
sitting on a bed
watching Westerns?"
And then JB goes,
"How do you know that?"
[ Laughter ]
And then I have to spend 15
minutes explaining to this man
that I am not the government,
alright?
I don't even know
what JB did in his life
to think the po-po
would still be after him.
[ Laughter ]
It was insane.
And so finally, I can hear him
trying to get
my granddad's attention.
And through the receiver,
I can hear him
and hear my granddad be like,
"Can't you see
I'm watching something?
Leave me alone. I'm busy."
Right?
So then JB goes "I don't think
he wants to talk."
So then I just talk to JB.
And honestly, it's nice.
It's like having two granddads
again, you know?
[ Light laughter ]
'Cause I don't know
if you're all as well-versed
with old Black men as I am.
I don't know if they're
as intimately in your lives,
but is it just me,
or when old Black men
are about to fight,
doesn't it sound like
they're about to tear
into a piece of pie?
They're just standing in front
of each other like, "Mm-hmm.
[ Chuckles ] Mm-hmm.
Alright. Okay.
Mm-hmm-hmm.
You about to get it, alright?
You about to get beat,
alright? Alright?"
And then they give you
the recipe of the fight.
Like, "I'm-a take these hands,
alright?
I'm-a put a little foot
in it, okay?
I'm-a add some cane to it."
[ Laughter ]
I've been watching a lot of TV.
And I've been watching
a lot of rom-coms especially.
And I don't know
if this bothers anybody else,
but does it trip you out
that everyone in a rom-com has
enough money to make it work?
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean? Every
rom-com scenario is the same.
It's like boy meets girl.
Boy falls in love with girl.
Boy messes it up.
Boy buys a last-minute, day-of
flight to Australia, one way,
to get past the gate
and stop girl
from taking a life-changing
opportunity across the world.
It's like, I don't have
last-minute flight money,
alright?
[ Laughter ]
Like, even if I managed
to get that ticket,
I now have to go with you
to Australia,
whether I win you back or not,
you know?
Just running -- running
onto the plane
like, "Sheila, look,
I'm so sorry, okay?
I'm sorry, alright?
I was stupid. I was dumb.
I cared more about my friends
than the things that were
important to me, which is you.
You're the most
important thing to me.
You make me better,
you make me whole,
and I just want you
to take me back, alright?
Will you?
No? Okay, well, move over,
'cause I'm window.
Alright? I --
[ Laughter ]
I really thought
this would work,
but, you know, buckle up
for 16 hours of awkward."
Like, just once, I want to see,
like, a realistic rom-com,
you know?
I want to see a rom-com where
they can't afford to break up.
You know? Like, boy meets girl,
boy falls in love with girl,
boy messes it up,
boy wants to move out,
but in a fit of passion,
they signed a lease.
So looks like this is life for
the next six months, playboy.
Guys, I'm Josh Johnson.
Thanks so much.
You have a great night.
Appreciate it.
Thank you so much
for coming out.
-Josh Johnson!
For more info, go to
joshjohnsoncomedy.com.